I've written out two numbers
here, and they both contain 4.
They each have 4
as a digit, and I
want to think about what
the values of these 4's are
and to actually compare them.
So I encourage you
to pause the video
and try that out on your own.
So let's look at
the two 4's here.
So in 110,413, I have
a 4 right over here.
And what does that
actually represent?
Well, this is the ones place.
You have three 1's.
You have one 10's.
And the 4 is in
the hundreds place.
You have four 100's.
So this 4 literally represents
4 times 100, or 400.
Now, what about this 4?
Well, once again,
you have zero 1's.
You have five 10's.
You have three 100's.
And you have four 1,000's.
So this literally represents
4 times 1,000, which is 4,000.
So we can now compare the two.
The 4 in 110,413 is 1/10 the
value of the 4 in 54,350.
And it makes complete sense.
This 4 is one place to
the right of this 4.
This 4 is in the thousands.
The magenta-circled
4 is in the hundreds.
So every time we move a
place value to the right,
each increment
represents 1/10 as much,
assuming we have the same digit.
So a 4 in thousands is 4,000.
A 4 in hundreds would
be 1/10 as much.
A 4 in the tens would
be 1/10 as much as that.
So we could write a sentence.
Let me write it this way.
The value of the
4 in this number
is 1/10 the value of
the 4 in this number.
I know it's a little
bit weird sentence.
The value of the 4 in 110,413
is 1/10 the value of the 4
in 54,350.